hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
serialize and deserialize a binary tree
basically what we're trying to do is
we're given a binary tree right and we
want to write two functions for it
serializing it and then deserializing it
when we serialize we're taking an object
right and this object
in memory it could be anything right
like you don't know where this node
could be
in memory you don't know where this node
could be we know that there's some links
and stuff connecting them all together
but
what we want to do is take this and put
it into a very easy to read
string that could be passed around
easily right so basically
for example we could convert basically
we could convert
this entire tree into a string something
like this right
one is the root node then there's a two
then there's a three then there's a
couple nulls because two doesn't have
any children
and then there's the other nodes four
and five right basically
this is something that's easy to use and
pass around right
and we also wanna be able to take a
string like this and then turn it
back into a tree so we have to keep that
in mind it's something that could be
you know taken back and forth easily
reversed so there's a lot of different
ways to solve this problem
i'm gonna show you a pretty easy and
straightforward way to do it
you could use breadth first search
basically taking the tree and then
serializing it level by level
and then you know reading through the
input level by level
etc but there's also a way to do it with
depth first search using
pre-order traversal and i'll show you
this way because it requires a little
bit less code
so like i mentioned we're going to be
doing this with pre-order traversal so
let's just see
what would a tree like this if we
converted it into pre-order traversal
into the form of a string what would it
look like well obviously the first
value is one so we're gonna say okay the
root note is one right that's what
pre-order means we're gonna do the first
node
then we're gonna recursively do the left
subtree with pre-order
traversal and then similarly after that
we're going to do the right subtree in
pre-order traversal
now obviously we want to be able to
separate values
so we're going to use a comma as a
delimiter but you could use a space if
you really wanted to
or use something else but i'll just use
a comma so now let's recursively do the
same thing for the left subtree so
obviously we have a two
let's add that too because we're doing
pre-order and now let's do the left and
right subtree of two so first let's go
to the left subtree
now we're gonna see null right this is
null it's empty there's nothing there
but we are gonna add that to our string
just to indicate to us that this
left portion of the subtree cannot be
continued right and
you could add the word null but i'm just
going to use a capital letter n to
indicate that so that's going to be our
special value that indicates an
empty no node or empty tree since we
finished the entire left subtree and we
know that it was a null right so that's
basically our base case that tells us we
can't go any farther here so now what's
our right subtree for two it's also
null so we're going to add another null
and see how we've done the entire left
subtree here
so now we can start going down the right
subtree
so of course the first value is a three
so let's go ahead and add that
and similarly we're going to do
pre-order traversal on the left subtree
now you can basically see
this is the exact same thing that we did
up here right
2 was a node and two had no children so
left and right child of two were null
that's the same that's true for this
four node so we're gonna add
four and then we're gonna add the two
null nodes basically indicating that
four
does not have any children n
n so now let's go do the right subtree
basically you
can probably tell what i'm going to do
here so i'm running out of space so
let's put the five down here
comma and then a couple empty null nodes
and now we're done right that was the
entire string
so now i'm going to get rid of this tree
and we're going to see
is it even possible for us to be able to
take a string like this
and know exactly which one is going to
be the left node and which is going to
be the right etc etc right well we're
obviously going to use
pre-order traversal on this string
basically
to create a new tree and i'm going to
show you that it is
possible that this string is actually
not ambiguous
because clearly you can see okay one is
going to be the root note then the next
value must be the left if this were a
null
that would mean that one has no left
subtree right so we could just put
null for its left subtree but clearly
this is not null
so that means two is the left child of
one
next we see okay let's create the
subtree for
two right well it's left child is null
and next it's right child is also
null so therefore two is not going to
have anything right so
that's basically the idea so now let's
actually do it okay since we know we
created the string with pre-order
traversal that's basically the idea
we're going to use so we're going to
have a pointer
we'll call it i that's going to
basically tell us what index
of this string that we're at well in
reality what we're going to do we're
actually going to take this string
and then split it based on the delimiter
comma so then it's actually going to be
an array but i'm not going to redraw
that just because
it's pretty straightforward what we're
going to be doing with this string
so first one is non-null so it's a one
right so we
are going to create a root node with the
value one
now let's create the left sub tree
similar to pre-order traversal right
we're creating the node now then we're
gonna do the left subtree then we're
gonna do the right subtree the question
you might have is
how do we know when the left sub tree
stops
and when the right sub sub tree starts
i'm going to show you it's actually
simpler than you might think
so we know that the first value here is
going to be the left
child if this were null we would put a
null here but it's not null it's two so
we are creating a
two node over here and once again
recursively creating
this subtree so start with the left so
this first value is going to be the left
subtree it's a
null right so since it's a null that
means we can't continue
this subtree anymore right so that means
whatever value
so we're done with this first null now
whatever value comes
next here is going to be the value in
the right subtree
of this two node it happens to also be
null but maybe if it wasn't unknown
maybe it could have been a three right
that's when we would put three over here
but clearly it's not it's a null so that
means
we can actually stop this subtree
as well so since both of the children
were null
that means we're actually done creating
this entire subtree
we reached our base case basically so
we're done with this
now the next value that comes in our
string is clearly going to be the right
child of one so the three is gonna be
the right child
here and now of course pre-order
traversal we're gonna fill in the left
subtree of three so what's the next
value
in our string it's a four so this does
have a left subtree
four continuously we're going to be
doing the left subtree of four
we see it's a null that's our base case
so we're done with the left sub tree of
four
next we're looking for the right subtree
of four so what's the next value in our
string it's again
null so we reach the base case we can be
done
with this entire subtree so we're gonna
pop back up recursively over here to
three
and now we know we need to fill in the
right subtree it could be null or it
could be a real value let's find out
well the next value in our string is a
five so therefore
this is going to be five so next we see
that okay left child of five is going to
be null and
right child of 5 is going to be null
right so clearly what you can see here
is that for every single leaf node we
have
in our tree we we specified what their
children were going to be we specified
the leaf node two has two null children
leaf node four has two nulls and leaf
node five has two nulls
that's how you know we're done with the
entire string we're
we're gonna stop here we know that
there's nothing left to do
right every single leaf had null
children therefore we can't possibly
continue this tree right so we're done
so that's why it's not ambiguous and by
the way what do you think the time
complexity of this was well we know that
pre-order traversal is pretty linear
right so
basically o of n for serializing and for
d
serializing this problem is actually a
little simpler than you might think
for a hard problem at least so now with
that being said let's jump into the code
so good thing for us we only have to
fill in two functions so let's start out
with the serialize so we're going to be
given a root node for a tree and we want
to convert it into a string and then
return that string so let's start
with a empty string initially right
and actually just to make things a
little bit easier i'm going to
set our result to an array i'm basically
going to be adding
strings together like for example if we
had a node 1 i'm going to add it like
this if we add a node 2 i'm going to add
it
like this and then at the end i'm
basically going to be joining all the
strings together with a comma
delimiter so i'm going to define a
function inside a function just because
it's easier once again right so this is
going to be our pre-order depth first
search we are going to be passing in the
current root or the current node that
we're visiting
and of course we know that the base case
is if the node is
null and in that case what are we going
to do our special character that we're
going to define
is going to basically be a n character
so to result i'm going to append
and end character and then we're going
to return
if it's not null then we know we can
append we can we're since we're doing
pre-order we're going to be appending
before we recursively do depth for
search we're going to append
node.val but we know it's going to be an
integer so we're going to we're going to
convert it into a string so node.val
converted into a string
appended to result after that of course
we just call our recursive different
search
on the left and right subtree so uh debt
for search on node.left
and depth for search on node.right and
we don't even have to call our return
function because once this is done
executing it's going to basically return
by default
so once that is done we know that our
result is going to contain
all the strings that we want it to so
basically what i'm going to do is return
the result joined by a
comma delimiter so comma dot join
everything in result oh but i almost
forgot we actually have to
remember to call our debt for search
function so i'm going to call it passing
in the root value
so our serialized function is actually
just as simple as that so
next we're going to be moving on to our
deserialize function so we're going to
be given the data right
we know that the data is going to be
comma delimited so we're basically going
to split it
based on that comma into an array a list
of
the data that we're going to be needing
so i'm just going to call that vals
and i'm also going to create a pointer
i'm going to call it self.i
self because it's going to be a member
variable of this class
basically because we want it to be
global because i'm about to define
another
recursive function inside of this
function and i don't even need to pass
any variables into it because
the self.i is global so i'm going to
initialize this to 0 indicating we're
going to start at the first
value in our list of values and so once
again we're going to start with the base
case now what's the base case going to
be well if our
pointer is pointing at a value in the
vowels
and if that value happens to be null now
how do we know if it's null
well that's pretty easy right we can say
vals at index
self dot i and if it happens to be equal
to the character n
we know that's null so what are we going
to do we're just going to return the
base case we're going to return
a null node if it's not null that means
we have some work to do right we have to
create a tree node
with that particular value but we know
this valves
at self.i we know this is going to be a
string right so
and we know that tree nodes have integer
values so we're going to convert this
into an
integer before we pass it in and so this
node is going to be referred to
as node one thing i actually almost
forgot
if we're create if we're saying that the
value at this vowels
is null so we're basically saying we're
done visiting this right we're returning
null for this n in our values array so
before we return we want to make sure
that we increment i so self.i
plus one so that next time we go we call
a function
that we're at the appropriate value in
our list of values
and that's exactly what we're going to
be doing down here too right so since
we're already using
the value at self.i once we create this
tree node we know we have to increment
our pointer i so that we can be moving
on to the next
value that we need to create a node for
so i'm going to call depth first search
remember we don't actually have to pass
any parameters into this and the return
value for this is going to be the sub
tree i created
for node dot left it could be null
or it could be something else now after
calling the step for a search function
we don't have to increment self.i
because that's going to be happening
recursively so
once this is done we're going to do the
exact same thing for the right subtree
so
uh node.write is also going to be
basically whatever debt for search
returns for us
and once all of that is done we know
that we can simply return the node the
root node that we ended up creating
and then once that's done we've
basically defined our debt for search
function so what are we going to do
we're just going to call that debt for
search function
and return the result because for this
function we're taking in a string of
data and then converting it into a tree
and then returning that tree
this problem is not too bad if you do
have a pretty good understanding of
depth first search or pre-order
traversal or you know just
general binary tree traversals you could
do this with breadth-first search if you
really wanted to it just takes a little
bit more code but you can see that this
is a pretty efficient enough solution
this is about as good as it gets so i
hope that this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching